hi there check out this video so the
there's a coke can and there's a spill a
coke spill so the instructor here says i
spilled my coke on the table how would
you
throw it away and bring me something to
help clean so the robot here forms a
plan as it goes about it first it says i
would find a coke can
then second i would pick up the coke can
you can see it has done it
third i would go to the trash can fourth
i would put down the coke can note that
he puts down the coke can next to the
trashcan not in the trashcan because the
robot is environmentally friendly and
wants to preserve the can for the
recycling bin for cans and
you know it doesn't belong in the trash
good little robot so next it says i will
find a sponge i will pick up the sponge
and then will it clean the coke
no it will not clean up the spill it
will actually give the sponge to the
human to clean up this spill
because that's how the future is gonna
be the robots they're not gonna take our
you know people people always think the
robots will take our dirty jobs they'll
take all the like the these tasks like
cleaning and doing things
they'll abuse us the humans to do that
they'll just throw down our stuff
they'll throw down the sponge and be
like here human clean up your own mess
well that's if that's a future that you
look forward to to then join me in
today's paper we're going to look at do
as i can not as i say grounding language
in robotic affordances by researchers at
robotics at google and everyday robots
so as you saw in this video what
happened here is that from a simple
instruction that the instructor gave uh
this essentially this i spilled a coke
can you know please help me find
something to clean and throw it away the
robot formed a plan the plan you can see
at the very end here
you can see it developing in the bottom
at the very end you can see the full
plan i'm not sure if i can make this
bottom thing go away in essence it makes
a plan like it it always plans the next
step or at least it determines what the
next step should be and then it actually
also does it so this is a good example
of grounded a grounded language model or
also an example of embodied intelligence
this work connects large language models
and the knowledge that are that is
inherent to large language models with
the skills of robots that act in the
real world which really cool and usually
these two things are quite disjoint but
this could be really powerful
so we're going to look at this paper i
also have already recorded an interview
with the authors uh this for
time reasons we did it the other way
around this time so i don't want to take
away too much on the paper review right
here i'll tell you what the method is
about how it works and i'll leave the
rest to the authors who are extremely
competent and i learned i learned like i
learned a lot in the interview i hope
you will too
in any case the interview will be out
tomorrow if you're watching this the day
it comes out which obviously you do
how do you find new papers frankly
machine learning has become unbearable
there are thousands of new papers each
month and to keep the overview we need
good tools today's sponsor is zetta
alpha which is a search and
recommendation engines for papers this
is really powerful for example here i've
searched for today's paper say can you
can immediately see that not only do i
get the paper itself but i also get an
aggregation of all the social media
mentions of this paper it doesn't stop
there with one click i can find related
papers these are not only papers that
are cited but these are semantically
similar papers this is powered by neural
search which is really cool i can
further now add this paper to my tags
and what that will do is it will build
categories of papers and then serve me
recommendations that semantically fit
those categories this is really powerful
essentially this is a news feed of
papers that is personalized to you
specifically just recently z2 alpha has
released their own pdf reader this is
really strong right out of the gate not
only does it let you read the paper you
know but also it shows the important
information about a paper and it lets
you take notes now what i find by far
the coolest thing is that you can
actually use one of these notes to
search for other papers so whenever you
find something within a paper that seems
interesting you can use that particular
piece of text and go search for other
papers that might deal with the same
topic sign up now to zetta alpha there
is a free tier and the pro tier is
actually free for students for academics
but in case you are not one of these the
promo code yannick will get you twenty
percent of the pro subscription
the authors here state that if you try
to ask a language model
to clean a spill as they just did in the
video
so if you ask a language model to clean
a spill it might result in a reasonable
narrative as we've all come to know the
large language models like gpt3 or so
they give very convincing outputs so
when you ask them how would you clean up
spill they'll give you a reasonable plan
to clean up a skill
but the authors say may not be
applicable to a particular agent such as
a robot that needs to perform this task
in a particular environment they have a
bunch of examples right here so i
spilled my drink how can you help is up
here gpd3 would say something like you
could try using a vacuum cleaner well
gpd3 has no idea of a whether there is a
vacuum cleaner in this environment or b
whether the robot or whatever agent is
capable of executing that action so it's
capable of handling a vacuum cleaner
because it's not it's not the easiest
thing to use
um you have to go get it plug it in and
so on there's moving parts
uh similarly models like lambda and flan
of course they're made for different
things but still they will pay no
attention to what is actually possible
in the environment now you can get
around this a little bit by prompting by
prompt engineering
telling the model what's possible in the
current world but it will only get you
so far so we need something else we need
something better than this and that's
where this system comes in
so they say
uh what they want to do they provide
they want to provide a real world
grounding by means of pre-trained skills
and this leads to a situation where you
only consider actions that are both
feasible and contextually appropriate so
these two things need to be brought
together the language model
supplies the high level semantic
knowledge about the task and the robot
itself or the policy in the robot
provides the feasibility of the of the
tasks to be executed so the two things
are brought together contextually
appropriate from
um
contextually appropriate from the
language model side and feasibility from
the robot side
so how are they going to do this
they're going to combine
as i said large language models with
policy
or
value functions let's say value
functions and then they execute a policy
there's a bit more explanation right
here but i think i've said many things
already
we'll get to the we'll get to the meat
right here
they say
let's say we have a robot
the robot might be or in this case is
equipped with a repertoire of learned
skills for basic atomic behaviors
these skills are capable of low level
perception and control
so one of these atomic behaviors is for
example
if you remember from the video
pick up something like pick up the coke
can that's an atomic behavior you can
teach the robot to pick up a coke can in
isolation it can do it many times you
can
train some imitation learning or
reinforcement learning or you can even
hard code
that particular policy it doesn't matter
what matters is that you can train it in
us
sorry in isolation it is an atomic
action
and
these atomic actions can then be chained
together to form a sequence of actions
and execute a plan
so
the
atomic actions are going to be supplied
by the robot and then the sequencing of
the atomic actions is going to be
determined by the language model
they say if we can simply make the large
language model aware of the available
and feasible repertoire of skills this
can provide it with an awareness of both
the agent's capabilities and the current
state of the environment
so if they have a large language model
many people use large language models to
sample which means that they input they
would input something like you know i
oh i is capitalized i spilled
a drink
dot dot and then they would let the
language model generate stuff right here
and then they would try to interpret
this stuff we've seen this in other
paper and there are situations where it
can work especially if you put like some
reasonable prompt in front of it
but the approaches have been largely to
just let the model generate some stuff
and then
try to
map that stuff whatever comes here
into the action space of the robot but
that is not always possible instead what
this paper does is it says well
we can also use the language model not
to generate but simply to compute the
likelihood of certain inputs so i
spilled a drink
and then let's say i just have five
actions at my disposal
all the robot can do is these five
actions so
i
would
or let's let's say it says
i spilled a drink
i
will
and then
um
clean
up
i will
go away
i will eat
pizza
i will and so on right so there are
these different actions that the robot
has available to do and these correspond
obviously directly to these atomic
actions so cleaning up something would
be an atomic action that you could train
in isolation
go away going away would be an atomic
action you can hard code or you can path
find your way out the door right eat
pizza maybe these are even too high
level that the way that i scribe right
now but just imagine these are low level
actions
and all we have to do with the language
model is we simply have to compute the
likelihood of each so what's the
likelihood of the sentence
i spilled a drink i will clean up right
and then i compare that to the
likelihood of the sentence i spill the
drink i will go away
and then i compare that to the
likelihood of the sentence i spill the
drink i will eat pizza so for every
continuation here in my repertoire i
will get a likelihood number and that
represents how contextually appropriate
is that particular skill in this case so
how much does the language model think
this skill would be useful right here
now there's obviously an issue in how
you formulate these things right here
depending on how you formulate them they
might become more or less likely however
i think the authors here work around
this simply by the fact that these
skills that they have uh they are so
separated from each other there is not
really
too much of an issue with that but
that's that's kind of what um my concern
was when i read this but in essence it's
a good idea i think
so
you you simply for every single wow
this all became orange for every single
continuation you get a number which is
the likelihood of that thing
that's what they say right here you know
instead of using the large language
model to interpret an instruction
we can use it to score the likelihood
that an individual skill makes progress
towards completing the high level
instruction
furthermore and that's where the second
part comes in if each skill has an
accompanying affordance function that
quantifies how likely it is to succeed
from the current state such as
a learned value function its value can
be used to weigh the skills likelihood
it's best if we go down here to the
diagrams of how this works so you can
see how this fits together
this part here is the part we just
described
i let's say i'm in a situation
this is the prompt that i put in how
would you put an apple on the table
you you um
prompt well you prompt the language
model with this thing right here which
has a prompt engineering part so you can
see there are a bunch of
examples of instruction and then a
sequence of steps again again
instruction a sequence of steps here
comes again instruction and then here
you'd get a sequence of steps however
instead of generating you simply score
the likelihood of each of the skills
that you have available find an apple
find a coke find a sponge pick up an
apple pick up the coke yada yada until
go to the counter each one of these
skills gets a likelihood number assigned
to it that's part one
part two
is
where you train the robot for these
basic skills these atomic skills here
you can see one of these training
stations where you can simply teach the
robot to do
things such as picking up an apple or
picking up a red bull can now
what you have to do is not only teach
the robot a skill but also train a value
function for it if you do
something like
a2c reinforcement learning you get the
value function directly out of that
algorithm if not you have to somehow
come up with a value function
that makes sense in any case what you
want to do is train a policy and a value
function and the value function is
important because it tells you from a
given input by the way the
low level policy has the picture here as
an input well obviously the language
model doesn't
uh now i believe with with flamingo by
deepmind that just came out today that
might actually change
but um
the the low level policy has the image
available so the value function given
this picture right here can tell you
pretty quickly
my i
my skill
that's called pick up the red bull can i
can i can execute that policy and i can
probably make it happen that's why the
value is relatively large here also for
the pick up the apple uh action the
value function tells you you know given
this picture right here i can probably
make that happen however when it's
pick up the water bottle pick up the bag
of chips and so on there is no water
bottle so the value function very
accurately says nah i cannot make that
happen if i execute that policy so the
value function gives you inherently a
score of given the current observation
how likely am i to succeed at a
particular skill
which is exactly
what we want
because that's the second part of our
puzzle so on the right here you see
another example where none of these
pickup skills picking up sorry not pick
up picking up skills
have any value because there are no
objects but in this case
maybe other actions would score very
highly in the value function for example
go and find a sponge like i can always
go and find something right and if i
know there's a sponge somewhere i'll
probably succeed so
in any case
this value function now we can combine
you can see we got a number for each
action from the language model how
likely is that action to
progress towards the goal
we got a number for each action from the
value function which is how likely is
this action to succeed given the current
observation and all we do now is
essentially multiply the two things
together uh if there are log likelihoods
we obviously want to add them but
in any case we combine the two numbers
and then we choose the skill that is the
best trade-off between
what makes progress towards a goal
and
what is feasible currently here is an
example
the input is how would you put an apple
on the table like
an apple so
the we query the language model with
this prompt here and the prompt
engineering we've seen before this is
not displayed here but it is the case
and the top actions that the language
model gives
are
pick up an apple you see that's the
highest action that we have place the
apple and only at third instance find an
apple however the language model has no
clue about the current state right
and that's where the value function come
in so this is the current observation
we ask the value function which skills
are you know doable in the current
environment in the current observation
so
the language the value functions say
well finding an apple finding a coke
finding a sponge these are pretty high i
could do this i could also go to the
table i could also go to the counter
right these are fairly doable however i
cannot
i cannot
place an apple or place a coke because i
don't have a coke in my gripper i can
also not pick up an apple or pick up a
coke because i don't see them anywhere
in the picture right here
so
even though pick up the apple was scored
highest by the language model it is now
severely down ranked because the value
function for this policy doesn't
isn't very confident that it will
succeed if you execute that right now
and therefore the action that is chosen
is the best trade-off which is find an
apple
then you can
see or not see but this is represented
here that
after this is done the policy is
executed so the find an apple policy is
executed the find an apple action is
added to the prompt and then the whole
process repeats but instead of
asking for the first step this whole
thing is now the prompt
including the instruction and we simply
ask the language model for the second
step and the input to the value function
is now the current updated picture so
here you see it succeeded in finding an
apple and now hopefully the second step
if we go through the same process again
is going to be the pick up
an apple
action
because
well that might already be high by the
language model but also the value
function given that there's an apple in
the picture should now say yes i can
probably succeed at that
so that's the whole the whole issue
or the whole process here uh this is
repeated until the end
this is yeah this is the say can method
uh they do like what what is really
impressive is just the amount of effort
and work that went into designing these
systems training these systems
evaluating these systems they have
different uh areas here on the left this
is like a kitchen on the right is a
different environment they have these
training stations they collect so much
data from human operators and so on this
is
if you saw that there are a lot of
authors is because this was
or seems like a quite big project
um but
yeah it's it's definitely worth it it's
cool to have something in the real world
there are definitely a bunch of
criticisms i have right here which i
also brought up to the authors and i i
thought they responded uh quite quite
admirably um
quite well
uh the
one criticism i already raised was that
if
you know it obviously depends on how you
spell so what what you have is this bank
of skills on the right hand side here
now in order for the language model to
score them they need to actually be
formulated as a piece of language
and now it all of a sudden depends on
how you formulate that for example we
know that longer
queries always have kind of lower
likelihood because they have more tokens
also how you phrase things is is
differently and so on so it is it is
quite tricky and i believe if you go
into more actions maybe um
actions maybe the robot has two actions
that are very
close together in terms of semantics or
in terms of wording
the
the
the model might get confused more easily
second of all
currently
there is no consideration as to whether
an action succeeds or not
so you simply assume that once you
execute the low-level policy that the
robot's going to succeed at executing
that low-level policy
that's why so if it doesn't succeed and
a lot of these things are still pretty
hard uh then
there there's
very little recovery
the value functions might still give you
like in like let's say you find an apple
you gra try to pick up the apple but you
don't manage to do it right
um
the pick up an apple instruction will be
pick up an apple will be in your prompt
now the value function would probably
say well i could pick up the apple again
because it again sees an apple because
you failed to pick it up but the
likelihood that the language model is
going to say pick up an apple again
after it just did
is quite
lower now i mean coincidentally as we
know language models if you go on here
repeating the sentence pick up an apple
at some point actually becomes pretty
likely given the language model
but hopefully we won't get there so
there are quite a number of weaknesses
yet
in this setup the other weakness is just
the limitations of hardware these robots
they are this video was 10x speed um so
this was 10 times speed and still it's
quite slow it as you can see it can't do
many things like it cannot
wipe itself with the sponge and so on it
needs to navigate around slowly um
yeah but still these are i think
limitations that can be overcome because
it like carefully grabs
and yeah
in any case there are also a lot of good
things right here
and i want to highlight that because
what i really like about this is that
these two things are disjoint so the
language model side
on the left hand side
and these value functions this policy
bank these atomic actions they are
disjoint the language model can is not
trained it is a frozen language model
it can be trained completely in
isolation to the system all you have to
do is get it to score the likelihoods of
some actions likewise the bank on the
right here it is completely
in fact not the bank itself but each
individual skill each individual entry
is trained completely isolated from all
the others all you need to add a new
skill right here is a policy
that can
execute that skill at any given moment
and a value function that estimates
given some state input that estimates
how likely the policy is to succeed if
this action if this policy were to be
executed at this particular moment
that's all you need you can add this to
your bank of actions and you have to you
don't have to retrain anything in this
system it is directly useful so you
could think of
shipping out these robots essentially
and then upgrading the language model so
they are better at planning stuff or you
could just ship new skills right he's
like well our coders have developed some
new skill for the robot right you just
amend you mend it you just put it in
there's no you don't need to update the
full system this is not an end-to-end
system and usually in deep learning
we're quite end-to-end happy but in this
case i think this is a really good case
where
modularity
is really the key i think this goes so
much beyond
just robots and grounding in the real
world but
to
have a model like on the on the left
that has knowledge about you know
semantic knowledge high level knowledge
and so on uh sequential knowledge
essentially
to provide that with a set
of of modular pieces of external things
that it can use i think that idea is
powerful way beyond
just the robotics use case but obviously
the robotics use case is quite a cool
one so i don't want to discourage that
um
yeah we in the interview we go into
all of this we go into the um
we go into the experimental results as
well uh the experimental results they're
not perfect
however they are quite impressive in
that the robots they are able to plan
across many many time steps they they're
able to chain these actions you can see
on the right here what's maybe two
pixels but these are like 17
of these atomic actions that are done in
sequence
and
you know that's that's quite impressive
these episodes are very very long and
if you think you can get to that in the
real world with sort of a reinforcement
learning approach then good luck
um yeah so the success rates are among
the
70
ish of planned success rate 61
execution success rate which
the planned success rate i believe is if
the plan itself makes sense and the
execution success rate is if also the
policies all execute correctly
and you can see this is very different
for the different test sets but all in
all
it's very impressive
here are a bunch of more examples of
these low-level atomic skills being
practiced and the value functions
being evaluated and the language
the language model
likelihoods in blue as well
so i don't want to make this
artificially too long uh as i said
interviews coming up i hope you like
explanations like these even if they are
a bit shorter and i'll see you around
check out the paper
subscribe stay hydrated bye bye